foreign
let's go to Maria in Richmond Virginia
what's up Maria
hello thank you for having me on the
show and thank you for calling what's up
um I was wondering how I could prepare
emotionally for having more kids when
the labor and postpartum experience was
my first kid was really bad in a word
tell me tell me what
anytime somebody says it was really bad
and they start laughing it was super bad
um tell me how tell me what really bad
means
um so I was in labor for over two full
days
um I had to transfer to a hospital when
I was planning on having a home birth
and I pushed for six hours
and
um
after he was born there was some like
when I was getting stitched up I could
feel it and I told the nurse to stop and
she didn't
um so like that was also not great and
then when we got home my son didn't
sleep for the first year of his life
um
yeah so like he's just over a year now
and he's just starting to sleep and I'm
just starting to feel
sort of like a normal person again human
again yeah so this was more
did you did you experience any
postpartum symptoms or was this just
like a
uh I I mean it was a traumatic birth
experience
yeah okay
um yeah I mean I do think there was some
postpartum and depression postpartum
depression and anxiety happening sure um
I'm that's just a guess I should have
gotten help and I didn't but um yeah so
man I I think your fear of what comes
next is legitimate and real
I mean it it was it it was a scary thing
and it was a painful painful thing and
it was a loss of control and it was
probably made worse by every one of your
girlfriends telling you it's so
beautiful lovely and great and you're on
Pinterest the week before and all these
birth are holding their babies and
smiling like it's all shiny and you know
you know what I mean it's like you had
this picture of what this was gonna be
and they're gonna lay your baby down on
your chest and it's gonna be skin to
skin contact and you're gonna feel this
moment and instead you're screaming and
your legs are so cramped up you can't
move and you'll go to the bathroom and
in six to seven weeks because whatever
and then yeah this kid won't sleep I
don't even like him even though it's my
baby and then I feel guilty and shameful
because I don't like my kid right it
just it's not how we drew it up right
yeah
so that's an accurate picture do you
want to have more kids
yes why what do you want to do why do
you want to go down this road again
oh when I'm like 70 I'll be really mad
if the thing that stopped me was being
scared of one year being difficult
[Laughter]
that's one way to look at it and I'm not
even gonna take that from you you are
allowed to have that as your as your
your picture
um
so a friend of mine
um she had a pretty remarkable
experience with postpartum and then she
ended up
um like you know making sense of that
making meaning of that by sitting with a
number of women who have different birth
experiences she's a professor at a med
school I'm really remarkable woman
um and she had a very similar
much more graceful approach than you but
she said like her approach was
um
picture your Thanksgiving table in 20
years
and then back it up to
today
and when we were discussing it back and
forth I asked her is is this a tell me
if this is a good analogy I want to have
X dollars in my retirement account in 25
years so what decisions do I need to
make right now knowing that
um it's going to take
this long for this to happen and she
said absolutely so here's what I would
suggest one is I would be really clear
with my OB GYN coming into this new
season and if it's time to get a new OB
GYN get a new get a new doctor okay okay
I wouldn't I wouldn't think twice about
that you had a terrible experience they
didn't listen to you or go back to the
if you trust this person and it was just
a weird experience or it's rushed or too
slow whatever
say I don't want to do this again
the second is somebody who has had
I mean you had a home birth in mind that
tells me you really researched this
thing right I want it to look like this
an experience it like this a lot of your
I don't want to be dismissive of the
pain and all that because that stuff is
super real and Wild
but a lot of your angst can come from
the gap between what you wanted to
happen and what actually happened
and often
the the that Gap I call it grief and
grieving like I wanted to be like this
and it wasn't there's something about
owning reality okay this is reality and
so this time I'm not gonna plan a home
birth or this time I am going to plan a
home birth and I'm going to be a little
more strategic about it whatever
it's owning what could actually happen
and here's the third part and this is
the not popular part
um and this is my friend told me this
and this is what the the clinical
literature says
if you've had a hard like a long
um labor
prep for it next time
before you get pregnant start an
exercise routine start a meditation
practice start eating right yeah get as
much sleep as you can with a with a
one-year-old and I'm saying that knowing
that's obnoxious but
um
put yourself in as good a physical
position as a physical shape as you can
knowing that you're gonna have to do 48
Hours of absolute physical health
you see what I'm saying okay and it will
give you some control it may not make
labor any nicer or not nicer or whatever
maybe just world class crap show but
let's give ourselves the best chance on
the front end let's control what we can
control right yeah and let's do the
let's let's put the money in the account
While We're Young while we can so that
when things happen down the road we're
ready for it and really I don't know
another I don't know a lot of other
options what do you think
no I think that's
I've already started to I've tried to
start doing that but again with a
one-year-old it can be kind of a joke it
can be but also
um don't let it be a joke I want you to
go to my friends
um the Mind pump guys and they have a
new Pro they have a whole list of
workout programs called maps maps and
they just released one called Maps 15.
it's a 15 minute workout that they use
and these dudes are Beefcake mcgeees
they're all smoke shows like Kelly and I
went to visit the studio and Kelly had
to catch her breath right they're like
shoot but but this workout program is 15
minutes a day you can do that with the
one-year-old you can't do that okay I
can do that you can get a couple of
dumbbells and a couple and you can do 15
minutes and my guess is my wife made a
really took the why to the cleaners on
the the child care
and she went to the gym for an hour
sometimes maybe two hours sometimes
maybe four hours until they were like
paging Miss deloney right but
um some of these gyms have free child
care and it might be a great way for you
to get some space to read a book to
journal some to exercise right take a
class be around other people so utilize
some of that stuff
um what I would say is
foreign
we have a real it's a cultural issue and
so I don't want to project this onto you
because it may not be the case in your
home but culturally speaking we've made
our children especially young kids the
epicenter of our planet
and I would suggest you control alt
delete your calendar a year in
and say okay I'm not going to go through
a day and not exercise
how is my kid going to be a part of that
not how can I fit exercise into my kids
world
okay I'm not budging on this so kid
you're coming to the Y child care and
you know what everybody's gonna live
it's gonna be fine and I'm gonna become
a mom who sleeps at night a mom who's a
little less stressed a little less
anxious because I'm I'm taking care of
myself I've got to go be with other
people so kid you're gonna have to
figure this out because mom's gonna go
be with her friends and other people
because
my world doesn't revolve around you
because your kid can't hold your world
right they're not strong enough to hold
the epicenter of your solar system so
I'm not even gonna let you do that
you're a moon you revolve around me
right and let's completely shift and
maybe that's something you sit down with
your husband and say hey
uh we're a year in we've survived let's
start building a life that we want not
settling for a life that we think we
have to have because we have this 14
pound screaming thing in the house that
poops and eats and never sleeps does
that make sense yeah
um as the great Rage Against the Machine
said Maria it's time for you to uh take
your power back right take ownership of
your home and take ownership of okay
I got my butt kicked last time during
um during labor it was rough
um
I lost control of the picture that I'd
planned so long for my body didn't
respond how I thought it was going to uh
I ended up in a in a physical exertion
like I physically exerting myself in a
way that I wasn't prepared for my nurse
didn't listen to me I had surgery
without anesthesia right all these
things here's what I can control going
ahead next time and recognizing it might
be really really rough again
and that's what we're going to double
down like you said I'm not gonna when
I'm 70 I'm gonna hate myself I would
probably wouldn't go there
but what's the table I want one in 20
years and what hard things do I have to
do now
and I do think sitting down with your
doctor and saying hey this was my
experience we're about to go around two
of this and I need to have a better
experience this time I need you guys to
listen to me better I need to plan
better and uh let's be on the same page
here but congratulations I'm sorry ah
I'm sorry it was so rough this time
control we can control get people in our
lives
and let's move forward best of luck to
you hey when this new baby's born number
two send us a picture and we'll post it
for you